principal component analysis
in machine learning my name is richard
kirschner with the simply learn team
www.simpler get certified get ahead
we talk about the principal component
analysis we're going to cover
dimensionality reduction
principle component analysis what is it
important pca terminologies
and you'll see it abbreviated normally
as pca
principal component analysis pca
properties
pca example and then we'll pull up some
python
code in our jupyter notebook and have
some hands-on demo on the pca and how
it's used
dimensionality reduction dimensionality
reduction
refers to the technique that reduces the
number of input variables
in a data set and so you can see on the
table on the right
shows the orders made at an automobile
parts retailer
the retailer sells different automobile
parts from different companies
and you can see we have company b-packs
isomax
and they have the item the tire the axle
an order id
a price number and a quantity in order
to predict the future cells
we find out that using correlation
analysis
that we just need three attributes
therefore we have reduced the number of
attributes
from five to three and clearly we don't
really care about the part number
i don't think the part number would have
an effect on how many tires are bought
and even the store who's buying them
probably does not have an effect on that
in this case that's what they've
actually done is remove
those and we just have the item the tire
the price and the quantity
one of the things you should be taking
away from this is in the scheme of
things
we are in the descriptive phase we're
describing the data and we're
pre-processing the data
what can we do to clean it up why
dimensionality reduction
well number one less dimensions for a
given data set means
less computation or training time that
can be
really important if you're trying a
number of different models
and you're re-running them over and over
again and even if you have seven
gigabytes of data
that can start taking days to go through
all those different models
so this is huge this is probably the
hugest part as far as reducing
our data set redundancy is removed after
removing similar
entries from the data set again
pre-processing
some of our models like a neural network
if you put in two of the same data
it might give them a higher weight than
they would if it was just once we want
to get rid of that redundancy
it also increases the processing time if
you have multiple
data coming in space required to store
the data is reduced
so if we're committing this into a big
data
pool we might not send the company that
bought it
why would we want to store two whole
extra columns when we added into that
pool of data
makes the data easy for plotting in 2d
and 3d plots
this is my favorite part very important
you're in your shareholder meeting
you want to be able to give them a
really good clear
and simplified version you want to
reduce it down to something people can
take in
it helps to find out the most
significant features and skip the rest
which also comes in in post scribing uh
leads to better human interpretation
that kind of goes with number four it
makes data easy for plotting
you have a better interpretation when
we're looking at it principle component
analysis
so what is it uh principal component
analysis is a technique for reducing the
dimensionality of data sets
increasing interpretability but at the
same time
minimizing information loss so we take
some very complex data set with lots of
variables
we run it through the pca we reduce the
variables we end up with a reduced
variable setup
this is very confusing to look at
because
if you look at the end result we have
the different colors all lined up
so what we're going to take a look at is
let's say we have a picture here
let's say you are asked to take a
picture of some toddlers and you
are deciding which angle would be the
best to take the picture from
so if we come up here we look at this we
say okay this is you know one angle
we get the back of a lot of heads not
many faces
so we'll do it from here we might get
the one person up front smiling
a lot of the people in the class are
missing so we have a huge amount off to
the right of blank space
maybe from up here again we have the
back of someone's head
and it turns out that the best angle to
click the picture from
might be this bottom left angle you look
at it you say hey that makes sense it's
a good
configuration of all the people in the
picture now when we're talking about
data it's not you really can't do it by
what you think is going to be the best
we need to have some kind of
mathematical
formula so it's consistent and so it
makes sense in the back end
one of the projects i worked on many
years ago
has something similar to the iris if
you've ever done the iris data sets
probably one of the
most common ones out there where they
have the flower
and they're measuring the stamen in the
petals and they have width and they have
length of the petal
instead of putting through the width and
the length of the petal
we could just as easily do the
width to length ratio we can divide the
width by the length and you get a single
number where you had two
that's the kind of idea that's going on
into this in pre-processing and looking
at what we can do to bring the data down
the very simplified example on my iris
pedal example when we look at the
similarity
in pca we find the best picture or
projection
of the data points and so we look down
at from one angle
we've drawn a line down there we can see
these data points based on in this case
just two variables now keep in mind
we're usually talking about 36
40 variables almost all of your
business models usually have about 26 to
27
different variables they're looking at
same thing with like a bank loan model
we're talking 26 to 36 different
variables they're looking at that are
going in
so we want to do is we want to find the
best view in this case we're just
looking at the x
y we look down at it and we have our
second
idea pc2 and again we're looking at the
x i this x
y this time from a different direction
here for our e's we can consider that we
get
two principal components namely pc1 and
pc2 comparing
both the principal components we find
the data points are sufficiently spaced
in pc1
so if you look at what we got here we
have pc1 you can see along the line how
the data points are spaced versus the
spacing in pc2
and that's what they're coming up with
what is going to give us the best look
for these data points when we combine
them and we're looking at them from just
a single angle
whereas in pc2 they are less spaced
which makes the observation and further
calculations much
more difficult therefore we accept the
pc1 and not the pc2 as the data points
are more spaced
now obviously the back-end calculations
are a little bit more complicated when
we get into the math of how they decide
what is more valuable this gives you an
idea though that when we're talking
about this we're talking about the
perspective
which would help in understanding how
pca
analysis works we want to go ahead and
do is dive into the important
terminologies
under a pca and important terminologies
are views
the perspective through which data
points are observed
and so you'll hear that if someone's
talking about a pca presentation
and they're not taking the time to
reduce it to something that the
average person shareholders can
understand you might hear them refer to
it as the different views what view are
we taking
dimension number of columns in a data
set are called the dimensions of that
data set
we talked about you'll hear features
dimensions
i was talking about features there's
usually when you're running a business
you're talking 25 26 27 different
features
minimal and then you have the principal
component new variables that are
constructed as
linear combinations or mixtures of the
initial variables
principal component is very important
it's a combination
if you remember my flower example it
would be the
width over the length of the petal as
opposed to putting both width and length
in you just put in
the ratio instead which is a single
number versus two separate numbers
projections the perpendicular distance
between the principal component
and the data points and that goes to
that line
we had earlier it's that right angle
line of where those point
how those points fall onto the line
important properties
important properties number of principal
components is always less than or equal
to the number of attributes
that just makes common sense uh you're
not going to do
[Music]
10 principal properties with only three
features
you're trying to reduce them so it's
just kind of goofy but it is important
to remember that people will throw
weird code out there and just randomly
do stuff with instead of really thinking
it through
principle components are orthogonal
and this is what we're talking about
that right angle from the line
when we do pc1 we're looking at how
those points fall on to that line
same thing with pc2 we want to make sure
that pc1 does not equal pc2
we don't want to have the same two
principal points
when we do two points the priority
of principal components decreases as
their numbers
increase this is important to understand
if you're going to create one
principle component everything is
summarized
into that one component as we go to two
components
the priority how much it holds
value decreases as we go down so if you
have five different points
each one of those points is going to
have less value than just the one point
which has everything summarized in it
how pca works i said there was more in
the back end we talk about the math
this is what we're talking about is how
does it actually work
so now we have understanding that you're
looking at a perspective
now we want to see how that math side
works pca
performs the following operations in
order to evaluate the principal
components for a given data set
first we start with the standardization
then we have a covariance matrix
computation
and we use that to generate our i gene
vectors and i gene values
which is the feature vector and if you
remember the i gene
vector is like a translation for
moving the data from x equals one to x
equals two or whatever we're altering it
and the ig value is the final value that
we generate
when we talk about standardization the
main aim of this step is to standardize
the range of the attributes so that each
one of them
lie within similar boundaries this
process
involves removal of the mean from the
variable values and scaling the data
with respect to the standard deviation
and you can see here we have z equals
the variable values minus the mean
over the standard deviation the
covariance matrix
computation covariance matrix is used to
express the correlation between any two
or more attributes
in multi-dimensional data set the
covariance matrix
has the entries as the variance and the
covariance of the attribute values
the variance is denoted by var and the
covariance is denoted by
cov on the right we can see the
covariance matrix for two attributes and
their values
when we do a hands-on and look at the
code we'll do a display of this
so you can see what we're talking about
and what that looks like
for now you can just notice that this is
a matrix that we're generating with the
variance and then the covariance of x to
y
on the right side we can see the
covariance table for more than two
attributes in a multi-dimensional data
set
this is what i was talking about we
usually are looking at not just one
feature
two features we're usually looking at 25
30 features going on and so if we do
a setup like this we should see all
those different features as the
different variables
covariance matrix tells us how the two
or more variables are related
positive covariance indicate that the
value of one variable is directly
proportional to the other variable
negative covariance indicate that the
value of one variable is
inversely proportional to the other
variable that is always important to
note whenever we're doing any of these
matrixes that we're going to be looking
at that positive and negative whether
it's inverted or not
and then we have the iogene values and
the i gene vectors
iogene values and hygiene vectors are
the mathematical value
that are extracted from the covariance
table
they are responsible for the generation
of a new set of variables from the old
set of variables
which further lead to the construction
of the principal components
gene vectors do not change directions
after linear transformation
i gene values are the scalars or the
magnitude of the i gene vectors
and again this is just chain
transforming that data so we're going to
change
the vector b to the b prime as denoted
on the chart and so when we have like
multiple variables
how do we calculate that new variable
and then we have
feature vectors feature vectors is
simply a matrix that has igen vectors of
the components that we decide to keep as
the columns
here we decide whether we must keep or
discard the less significant principal
components that we have generated in the
above steps this becomes
really important as we start looking at
the back end of this and we'll do this
in the demo
but one of the more important steps to
understand
and so we have the pca example consider
matrix x within rows or observations and
k
columns or variables now for this matrix
we would construct a variable space with
as many dimensions as
the variable but for our simplicity
let's consider this three dimensions for
now
now each observation row of the matrix x
is placed in the k dimensional variable
space such that the rows in the data
table
form a swarm of points in this space
now we find the mean of all the
observations and then place it along the
data points on the plot
the first principal component is a line
that best accounts for the shape of the
point swarm
it represents the maximum variance
direction in the data
each observation may be projected onto
this line in order to get a coordinate
value along the pc1
this value is known as a score
usually only one principal component is
insufficient to model the systematic
variation for a data set
thus a second principal axis is created
the second principle component is
oriented such that it reflects the
second
largest source of variation in the data
while being orthogonal to
pc1 pc2 also passes through the average
point
let's go ahead and pull this up and just
see what that means
inside our python scripting
i'm going to use the anaconda navigator
and i will be in python 3.6
for this example i believe there's even
like a 3.9 out
i tend to stay in 3.6 because a lot of
the models i use
especially with the neural networks are
stable in 3 6.
and then we open up our jupiter i'm in
chrome
and we go ahead and create a new python
3.
and for ease of use our team in the back
was nice enough to put this together for
me
and we'll go and start with the
libraries the first thing i like to do
whenever i'm looking at
any new setup well you know what let's
do let's do the libraries first
we're going to do our basic libraries
which is matplot library
the plt from the matplot library pandas
our data frame
pd numpy our numbers array np
seaborn for graphing sns that goes with
the
plot that actually sits on matplot
library so the seaborn sits on there
and then we have our amber sign because
we're in jupiter notebook matplot
library in line
the newer version actually doesn't
require that but i put it in there
either
anyway just because i'm so used to it
and then we want to go ahead and take a
look at the
data and in this case we're going to
pull in
certainly you can have lots of fun with
different data but we're going to use
the cancer data set
one of the reasons the cancer data set
is it has like 36 35 different features
so it's kind of fun to use that as our
base for this
and we'll go ahead and run this and look
at our keys
and the first thing we notice in our
keys for the cancer data set
is we have our data we have our target
our frame target names description
feature names and file name
so what we're looking for in all this
is let's take a look at the description
let's go in here
and pull up the description on here
i'm not going to spend a huge amount of
time on the description
because this is we don't want to get
into a medical domain
we want to focus on our pca setup
what's important is you start looking at
what the different attributes are what
they mean
if you were in the medical field you'd
want to note all these different things
whether what they're measuring where
it's coming from
you can actually see the actual
different measurements
are taking no missing attributes
we page all the way to the bottom and
you're going to have your data
in this case our target and if you
dig deep enough to the target let's
actually do this
let's go ahead and print target names
real quick here i always like to just
take a look and see what's on the other
end of this
target names
run that yeah
so the target name is is it malignant or
is it b9 so in other words is this
a dangerous growth or is it something we
don't have to worry about that's the
bottom line with the cancer in this case
and then we can go ahead and load our
data
and you know let me go up a just a notch
here for easy of reading
sorry to get that just right that's all
you have to do
uh so let's go ahead and look at our
data uh our we're gonna use our pandas
and we're going to go ahead and do our
data frame it's going to equal cancer
data
columns equals cancer feature equals
feature names so remember up here we
already loaded the
names up of our of the features in there
what is going to come out of this let me
just see if we can get to that
it's at the top of target names
that's just this list of names here in
the setup
and we can go ahead and run this code
and i'll print the head and you can see
here we have the mean radius the mean
texture
mean perimeter i don't know about you
this is a wonderful data set if you're
playing with it
because like many of the data that most
the data that comes in
half the time we don't even know we're
looking at we're just handed a bunch of
stuff as a data scientist going what the
heck is this
and so this is a good place to start
because this has a number of different
features in there we have no idea what
these feature means or where they come
from
we want to just look at the data and
figure that out
and now we actually are getting into the
pca side of it
as we've noticed before is difficult to
visualize high dimensional data
we can use pca to find the first two
principal components
and visualize the data this new
two-dimensional space
with a single scatter plot before we do
this we need to go ahead and scale our
data
now i haven't run this to see if you
really have to scale the data on this
but as just a general
run time i almost do that as the first
step of any
modeling even if it's pre-modeling as
we're doing here
in neural networks that is so important
with pca visualization
it's already going to scale it when we
do the means and deviation inside the
pca
but just in case it's always good to
scale it
and then we're going to take our pca
with the scikit
learn uses very similar process to other
pre-processing functions that come with
scikit-learn
we instantiate a pca object find the
principal components using the fit
method
then apply the rotation and
dimensionality reduction
by calling transform we can also specify
how many components we want to keep when
creating the pca object
and so the code for this
oops getting a little bit ahead let me
go and run this code
uh so the code for this is
from sk learn decomposition import pca
pca equals pca in components equals two
and that's really important to note that
because we're only going to want to look
at two components
i would never go over four components
especially if you're going to demo this
with somebody else
if you're showing this to the
shareholders the whole idea is to reduce
it to something people can see
and then the pca fit we're going to is
going to take the
scale data that we generated up here and
then you can see we've created our
pca model with in components equals two
now whenever i use a new tool
i like to go in there and actually see
what i'm using so let's go to the scikit
webpage for the pca
and you can see in here here's our call
statement it describes what all the
different
setups you have on there probably the
biggest
one to look at would be well the biggest
one is your components how many
components do you want
uh which you have to put in there pretty
much and then you also might look at the
svd solver it's on auto right now but
you can override
that and do different things with it it
does a pretty good job as it is
and if we go down all the way down to
there we go to our methods if you notice
we have
fit we have fit transform
nowhere in here is predict because this
is not
used for prediction it's used to look at
the data again we're in the describe
setup we're fitting the data we're
taking a look at it
we've already looked at our minimum
maximum we've already looked at what's
in each quarter
we've done a full description of the
data this is part of describing
the data that's the biggest thing i take
away when i come
zooming in here and of course i have
examples of it down here if you forget
and the biggest one of course is the
number of components and then
i mean the rest you can play with the
actual solver whether you're doing a
full
randomize there's different things it
does pretty good on the auto
and now we can transform this data to
its first two principal components
and so we have our xpca
we're going to set that equal to pca
transform
scaled data so there we go there's our
first transformation
and let's just go ahead and print the
scaled data shape
and the xpca data shape
and the reason we want to do this is
just to show us uh
what's going on here we've taken 30
features
i think i said 36 or something like that
but it's 30
and we've compressed it down to two
features and we decided we wanted two
features and that's where this comes
from
we still have 569 data sets
i mean data rows data sets we still have
569 rows of data
but instead of computing 30 features
we're now only doing our model on
two features
so let's go ahead and plot these and
take a look and see what's going on
and
we're just going to use our plt figure
we'll set the figure size on here
here's our scatter plot xpca
x underscore pca of of one
these are two different perceptions
we're using
and then you'll see right here c for
color
cancer equals target and so remember we
have zero
we have one and if i remember correctly
zero was malignant one was b9
so everything in the zero column is
going to be one color and the other
color is going to be
one and then we're going to use the
plasma map just kind of telling you what
color it is
add some labels first principle
component second principal component
we'll go and run this
and you can see here instead of having a
chart
one of those heat maps with 30 different
columns in it we can look at this and
say hey this one actually did a pretty
good job
of separating the data
and a couple things when i'm looking at
this that i notice
is first we have a very clear area
where it's clumped together where it's
going to be
b9 and we have a huge area it's still
clumped together more spread out where
it's going to be
malignant or i think i had that
backwards and then in the middle
because we're dealing with something in
this particular case
cancer we would try to separate i would
be
exploring how to separate this middle
group out
in other words there's an area where
everything overlaps and we're not going
to have a clear result on it
just because those are the people you
want to go in there and have extra tests
or treat it differently versus going in
and saying just cutting into the can
into the cancer so the body absorbs it
and it dissipates
versus actively going in there removing
it
testing it going through chemo and all
the different things
that's a big difference you know as far
as what's going to happen here
in that middle line where the overlap is
going to be huge
that's domain specific uh going back to
the data
we can see here clearly by using these
two components we can easily separate
these two classes so the next step is
what does that mean
interpreting the components
unfortunately with this great power of
dimensionality reduction
comes the cost of not being able to
easily understand what these components
represent
i don't know what principle component
one licks work represents or second
principle
the components correspond to
combinations of original features
the components themselves are stored as
an attribute of the filtered pca object
and so we talk look at that we can go
ahead and do look at the pca components
this is in our model we built
we've trained it we can run that and you
can see here's the actual components
it's the two components have each have
their own array
and within the array you can see the
what the scores are using
and these actually give weight to what
features
are doing what so in this numpy matrix
array each row represents a principal
component and each column
relates back to the original features
what's really neat about
this is we can now go in reverse
and drop this onto a heat map and start
seeing
uh what this means and so let me go
ahead and just
put this down upside down down here
we'll go ahead and put this in here
we're going to use our df comp data
frame
and we do our pca components and i want
you to notice how
easy this is we're going to set our
columns equal to cancer feature
names that just makes it really easy
and we're dumping it into a data frame
what's neat about a data frame
is when we get to seaborn it will pull
that data frame apart
and and set it up for us when we want
and so we're just going to do the cn the
seaborn heat map
of our data frame composition and we'll
use the plasma coloring
and it creates a nice little color graph
here you can see we have the mean radius
and all the different features along the
bottom
on the right uh we have a scale so we
can see we have the dark colors all the
way to
the really light colors which are what's
really shining there this is like the
primary stuff we want to look at
so this heat map and the color bar
basically represent the correlation
between the various features
and the principal component itself
so you know very powerful map to look at
and then you can go in here
and we might notice that the mean radius
look how how on the bottom of the map it
is um
on some of this so you have some
interesting
correlations here that change the
variations on that and what means what
this is more when you get to a post
scribe you can also use this to try to
guess as what these things mean and what
you want to change to get a better
result
and that wraps it up for principal
component analysis in
machine language
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here